c'est l'ensemble du pays clunysois qui
s'est réuni hier à la préfecture
soudés autour d'élus des missionnaires
venus protester contre l'exclusion de
leurs huit communes des zones agricoles
défavorisées
ces territoires remplissent pourtant
tous les critères pour toucher les aides
de la politique agricole commune
mais à la suite d'un arbitrage politique
les exploitations à l'école de ces
communes ne toucheront plus rien une
situation intenable pour ces immigrés
nous avons signé avec l'état des
engagements à maintenir les
exploitations d'élevage dans ces
communes parce qu'elles ont une valeur à
tous points de vue aussi bien économique
nourricière mais aussi environnemental
nous avons signé pour ça aujourd'hui
nous savons que ces engagements ne
seront pas tenues parce que l'état n'a
pas tenu de son côté est donc ça nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter
personne ne discute l'absurdité de la
situation tout le monde est d'accord
mais par contre de là à la corriger
y'a plus personne 29 exploitations sont
concernés par cette situation et les
risques aujourd'hui de mettre la clé
sous la porte en sortant de la zone
défavorisée
nous allons perdre landi l'indemnité des
handicaps naturels une exploitation
comme la nôtre ça représente vingt mille
euros de pertes ce qui représente
environ une perte de revenus par
associés par mois de 550 euros
les élus de ces communes se sont battus
pendant des mois pour éviter cette
situation
ils sont 14 à démissionner ultime
recours pour faire pression sur l'état